hello and welcome to see do playing a
light like Martin comes under a place
especially son all the time maybe I can
can alter the move audie a little bit
and then he goes he plays with c5 anyway
I avoided something here that I don't
need to avoid because he doesn't play it
in the first place ok maybe this is an
interesting try i don't know our
development might be a little bit to
slow him and why he probably gets NT 495
it's just no development at all i don't
believe in this that much so let's go an
idea three yeah probably be should be to
EST for right now yes got deform and and
equal infinity equalizers
yeah okay okay okay so this is probably
not the greatest movie ever mmm yeah
probably still blacken well what is he
doing now oh it's not that easy you too
and be okay so rude shakes yes but let's
still thought I'll take and go um [ __ ]
c7 rupee ate the soup itself so this one
ok so rope here 47 maybe
okay so night two is six SSID I am a
rookie aight i can trade and Luke takes
rook takes d4 and signs still what f4f
was probably better and it's still
annoying for black this pollution
yeah it's still not easy check okay
attention attention where to put it
group to d7
nice you will come up with a king
yeah I should have gone to see seven
it's nothing special really oopsie 796
rook be 79 th and nothing happens now
it's just nothing and yeah he played
that well to equalize
yeah potentially nabbit I mean have five
and stuff my bishop is so pretty good
and smaller bad Bishop him
mmm yeah it's raining looks I don't
really want to do
it shouldn't be a problem or anything
that night is a very good defender him a
very good defense check he force
blundering stuff it's not so great
I can be fine I'm just sleeping him i'm
not paying enough attention yeah i
didn't play that well of course he
definitely had some some opportunities
to do something why it still should lose
but I also never should have gotten into
this position in the first place
time morning shift you one III probably
up staying on that diagonal
ha ha ha I really don't like to play
stuff like that on time when I really
played it badly yeah i mean here i
should just keep a good good position
but i didn't manage i'm not saying i
should win I just say I should be the
one pressing it as absolutely didn't
manage to do that yeah maybe we'll see
one it could be equal I mean sometimes
think I just kind of yeah you you looks
good but it is not really that much and
I think yeah it's still equal I mean I
have some horns on dark squares avoid
and before them and Simpson metric coins
and it's just a draw yeah the real issue
is i think that move ollie is probably
not that millions what i did here think
he gets defined and doing stuff from
here is really difficult Jim probably
just a correct draw what can you do okay
well thanks for watching